should we all do corpse voices
we should all do corpse voices
i want to hear what aoc has to say
i was by the office did someone get
whispering
um admiring the exercise balls
and did the wiring
i'm imposter finally
yay oh wow this map is
wild
where's the body was something um
preventing you from hitting the report
button i was
walking right in front of you and i
found the body
right when no no i found the body
right as i was walking up oh no
i did not kill okay i did not
kill you she did not kill him this is
this is true i don't know
he plays league of legends
[Music]
no i swear i swear
oh my god i 100 know
100 know i was right there it was 100
aoc
i'm so sorry yeah i'm on the i'm almost
yeah
you just did it right in front of you
what kind of person
you did it right in front of you what
kind of person
for you but i
[Music]
she was definitely heard for me too and
unfortunately a dev got
killed there in the crossfire let's see
here the deal is
i was once i saw in preparation
i tried to watch some youtube videos
on like sick among us plays
as imposters and one of them is
one of them is to wait for everyone to
be in a crowd
and then kill someone and then nobody
will know what's going on
yeah all right
progressive here we go solidarity
and
south international aoc and adept and i
had all done tasks in uh the top of
reactor and we're just walking down
oh i can't believe i'm getting away with
that
south and left south and left oh
[Music]
oh my gosh
he was chasing me so bad like he's
laughing at how much he's spinning the
story
a hundred percent will now it was all
down his political skills
we won boys and girls and children of
all ages
[Applause]
there we go
you